before we jump into today's episode we
have a very exciting announcement and
that is that our merch just launched
yesterday if you go to bigmoodstore.com
you can scope it all out we got two
t-shirts and our favorite phrase that's
um well it's part of our favorite phrase
yeah so the full phrase is just like the
sun you two will rise out of darkness
and just like the moon no matter what
phase you're in you're always whole so
we created these shirts and it says no
matter what phase you're always whole
with the moon phases yeah we all super
relate to that yeah yeah i love the
color i love the vibrancy and the
company that we're working with for this
collab just produces the highest quality
garments so we couldn't wait to release
these we've been working on them for so
long and we also have these sweatshirts
these hoodies just in time for fall and
these are super super super high quality
hoodies they're really thick metal on
the drawstrings they're super thick and
soft and every wash they actually get
softer
rather than like getting more like you
know how sometimes sweatshirts get that
those balls yeah
yeah the pilling gross these don't get
that mm-hmm so we also have it in a
different color too oh yeah we have it
in lavender which is so pretty
definitely going to nab one of those but
i'm so excited go to bigmoodstore.com
it's very very limited stock
everything's super limited stock so i
don't know if how much is left because
they released yesterday but if they're
still there go check them out we'll put
a link in the description
thanks
[Music]
hi everybody welcome back to another
episode of big move
as you can see we have a beautiful guest
today who do we have stacy yes
yes stacey is
beautiful and not just that but she's
going to be with us on multiple episodes
today so there's going to be quite a few
more so stay tuned we're also going to
get to that one topic that we kind of
left you guys hanging on last time about
boys and girls not being friends and
maybe some of you wanted to know about
that so stay tuned not this episode or
maybe this week
watch the episode
we have a lot of episodes with her
coming up um you also have me gina
that's who you're hearing yeah and tiff
and nikki yay
jess is not here today we fired her
because we needed a diversity hire yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
now i'm here and you know the today's
episode is going to be easy we're just
catching up with everyone because one of
us
got big ass news
um last month someone else had big news
it was tiff we don't care anymore now we
have different videos
that you
um so why don't we start off strong
stacy tell us about your life what
huge what huge thing
what could it ever be
what a huge ginormous thing flush it
flush it
put on your sunglasses so for those that
are listening uh my
boyfriend proposed to me
yeah so he's not your boyfriend anymore
yeah no i know he's it's so hard to get
used to that isn't that a weird word it
is so weird especially because he'll be
like well i'm your fiance now and i'm
like i'm so
like it feels weird like to even tell
people i feel ridiculous like all my
fiance yeah it feels like you're saying
fancy [ __ ] yeah my beyonce yeah
it's weird in a way because for me it
feels like i'm in between jobs yeah you
know yeah like i'm not i don't have a
job right now but i'm also not at my
career i'm in between jobs i actually
liked that phase though because the
title is so much fancier than us my
husband yeah
yeah but i was going to say about
husband i feel like husband sounds so
together in a solid yeah i love husband
like i look forward to husband fiance
feels nice and it feels like being
called a wife yeah being called a wife
is probably amazing that's really hard
to get used to too like yeah on your
wedding day yeah like you're like oh
you're not my fiance anymore you're me
yesterday like oh my husband's going to
pick me up
like the first few times that comes out
of your mouth you're like oh my god i'm
such a grown-up yeah you know what word
annoys me and i don't know why it's been
like this since i was a teenager i
[ __ ] hate the word hubby oh yeah i
hate that i wouldn't use that me and my
hubby i like it it's cute he's he's
hubby in my phone yes same thing
language every day it's cute if you guys
use it it's just not my thing you know
or hugs danny's hubs is more something
yeah oh that one yeah i'm with you on
that one
the hub husband
um
wait i don't want to hear the juicy
desserts let me do it
let me tell you guys so there is a video
if you guys want to go watch it after
this
i thought it was super cute let me tell
you the tea so basically what happened
is
denny
tells me oh we're going to go have
dinner and we had actually gone on a
sunset day at the beach like to watch
the sunset yeah and he's like hey this
week we should go to dinner we haven't
got on a date in a long time and i was
like okay cool he's like can we do it on
the weekday because uh weekends are
really busy and i was like weird but
okay
and
then he tells me he's like when are you
gonna get your nails done and then i was
like
oh [ __ ] but i didn't want to get excited
i don't like to get excited because it
could be being so slick it's so funny we
catch every detail i just never asked my
nails before but all of a sudden i mean
you still have like i talked a lot about
my nails on my channel so i was like
maybe he's asking because of that i
don't know but i was like i'm just gonna
get them done just in case so we agreed
on wednesday we were gonna go have
dinner
and then he was like okay i'm going to
work wednesday and he's like he never
really texts me when he's at work so i
was like okay cool and
he gets off of work he's like hey i'm
off of work now blah blah blah and i'm
like okay so i'm getting ready
and my mom was over that day and then
she was like okay i'm gonna go home and
i've been helping her with her youtube
channel like she's been posting videos
like she started youtube yeah she's so
cute if you guys wanna watch spanish
videos go watch her what's her channel
name shout out to elissa vias so her
name yeah but she talks a lot about like
her relationship with god and she's also
doing cooking videos um mexican food
yeah cocaine for a second i was like
damn yeah
she goes
cocaine all right
no so anyway so my mom was over and
she's like i'm gonna go home get ready
and come back so i can film a video and
i was like why are you gonna go home
just film the video like she never gets
super ready or anything and she's like i
really want to get ready this time and i
was like okay we're whatever she's like
wait for me before you go to dinner and
then i was like okay sure so then she
goes home she comes back and she's like
extra
ready
and then i was like
yes
yeah so i was like well whatever i'm
still not gonna get my hopes up anyway
so then we're there and then um i'm like
okay danny's probably gonna be running
late like he's probably gonna want me to
iron his shirt and then he calls me he's
like baby can you iron my shirt and i'm
such a wifey already look at you i just
always do that for him because i just
love when people look well put together
you know especially him but anyway
you're like don't ruin my pictures
i just
i know whenever somebody has like a
wrinkly shirt i'm like a steamer is 30
dollars
a steamer and they could be ten dollars
on amazon you know like
it's not that hard but anyway so anyway
i was like y'all iron your shirt and so
he's like okay wait for me in the living
room i'll be right there and i'm like
okay so i'm sitting like this with my
mom the door's like right there and all
of a sudden our door is like digital is
that a thing like it goes
oh yeah and then it opens
so anyway i just hear that pee pee peep
and then the door opens and then i just
hear the mariachi start to play
yeah and then i was like holy kaka like
what is happening and then
danny walks in with this like huge yeah
how many
it was 350 flowers oh my god it was
ginormous now for those of you who don't
know me my boyfriend always gets me
flowers so
i think he really wanted to go out of
his way this time to like make it like a
special bouquet
so he walks in and then i was like i
just automatically started crying it
literally makes
us and he walks in and then the mariachi
walk in
and then they play this very beautiful
song
and then
danny waited for the song to be over but
he walked up to me with like the big
like thing of flowers and i was gonna
grab it he's like it's too heavy and
then i was like okay
so he just sets it down the song
finishes
and then he's like he says like a little
speech and he's like stacy like we've
been together and i just love you so
much and i think it's time for us to
take the next yeah and then he's like
do you want to be my wife oh you said
that yeah
she was all spanish and then i was like
oh yeah did he get the one he did yeah
he did and then i was like oh my god
ugly crying and then i just like went
down to hug him and he got up and then
they started playing a really beautiful
spanish song
if you guys know spanish you should go
listen to it it's so beautiful and so
they started playing another song and
then we like dance what was the
yeah
and so then after that we ended up going
outside to take pictures and my nature
went outside the neighbors came out to
listen it was so cute
um and then we ended up going to dinner
after to like celebrate because i did
tell him like obviously as you guys know
and you guys could probably relate our
careers are so out there and our lives
are so out there that i told them when
you do this like i would love it for it
not to be live for it to not be like
yeah recorded or uploaded like i want it
to be recorded but let us enjoy it oh my
god before because i already knew i was
gonna like and that's not a bad thing
but i already knew people were going to
be like congratulations congratulations
and i wanted to enjoy that the private
moment yeah that's exactly how what i
told steve because he wanted to do this
grand jester because um i heard he would
tell the story about how he asked his
girlfriend to go to prom with him and
like in front of the whole school like
on stage and stuff and i was like that's
really sweet but like if you ever
propose to me like i want it to be
between us like so it's like our moment
and not like
oh the audience like look at us like i
just want it to be like
although i do wish someone had recorded
a little bit of it because there's no
recording or picture or anything oh yeah
so i mean
jenny did know like i told them i do
want it to be recorded and my sister
vlogs too so she was vlogging for her
channel and um it worked out perfectly
because
i was like when we share it like the
moment in itself is special we should
share it with ourselves but then when we
share it to the world i also want to be
present in that when people start being
like hey congratulations and nice
messages because it's also like a
different
event yeah yeah with your videos like i
know exactly what you mean because it
was
recorded and it was
it was shared very intimately with your
family but also what he said to you was
so intimate and private you can't hear
it in the video or nothing so i actually
wanted to ask you that too like what did
he say to you when we were dancing or
like no like when he actually proposed
what you already said yeah that me
watching the video i'm like what did he
say like that's so sweet that they had
shared that like yeah bubble of a and
private it was crazy because obviously
the money at you were there my family
was there um and
it kind of just felt
like i love the fact that it was just my
family and us because i felt like we
could be just us you know we were
dancing we didn't have to worry about
like oh we have to tend to people we're
at a party like
it didn't feel like we had to like rush
out to like everybody hug us and stuff
which there's people who have been like
proposed to in parties and that looks
like so much fun
um but i love the fact that we had like
that moment between us
where we were like
like we danced after and we were
laughing he's like are you nervous and i
was like yeah i'm nervous
he's like me too like he's like do you
like your ring and i was like i haven't
seen it
because we were dancing you know and
like i didn't want to be like yes
so it was cute to share that moment what
i imagine to be like a first dance when
you're married you know because you're
like obviously a really big moment but
you're like it's just you too yeah
you're gonna [ __ ] cry
for sure i'm gonna cry the whole time i
have a question did you
tell him what kind of ring you wanted
beforehand yes picked it out and
everything so
i am very type a
very especially when it comes to jewelry
i sell jewelry i collect them myself i
love jewelry i love it i love it and
there's pieces that i have had
since i was younger when i had like i
mean now that i'm rich but like when i
had like three cents to my name that i
was like this ring is worth it and i'm
gonna pass it to my children like i have
those kind of pieces so
when we first met six months into dating
then he gave me a promise ring right and
so then we were like okay i want our
daughter one day to have this ring so
this is the ring that i'm gonna keep for
me forever right
so
um what we talked about things uh one of
the things we talked about was
what's our budget for the ring right
so we talked about budget and i think
most relationships and you guys can tell
me if you relate or not but you you have
a conversation before you get engaged
like is this gonna happen like are we
gonna do this are we moving forward in
our relationship
i don't know how it is for men but
when i see proposals where men like get
a no i'm like how did you not know she
didn't want to marry you i know like how
did you not talk about dudes yeah they
propose and they say no
you should know for sure like how did
you not
know so we had a conversation about it
and throughout the whole relationship it
was like oh when we get married when we
get married you know so anyway when i
got serious i was like okay so what are
we gonna do what's the budget for the
ring yada yada so um
my ring is not a diamond ring it's a
moistening ring oh yes i love moistening
rings and so the reason why i got a
moistened ring so a moistening is a
different gemstone so it's not a
replacement for a diamond it's just a
different gemstone yeah so the thing
that makes moist and night so good for
engagement rings is that and the
hardness scale for gemstones so i'm
gonna get technical into jewelry here i
love it yeah so diamonds are 10. so the
reason why diamonds are so expensive is
because one they're mined and two
because they're passed down from
generation to generation and what makes
them so valuable is that they won't
scratch they won't
they'll hold their shape and they won't
break
because they're a 10 on the hardness
scale right so for example if you think
of a ruby a ruby i don't know
specifically but it might be like a five
like a ruby my scratch an emerald my
scratch uh a moistenite stone is a 9.5
on the harness scale so it's just almost
just as hard as a diamond so this could
also be passed down from generation to
generation and then the fire which is
how like brightest shines is brighter
than a diamond so a diamond to get a
really good quality diamond you're
talking like 10 000 per
um carrot right so the moist nightstone
is a little bit more affordable there's
plenty of youtube videos if you guys are
looking to get engaged or if you want
another ring i definitely suggest that
you guys look into this it's also like a
more friendly option for the environment
since it's not mine no one can [ __ ]
tell like like honestly i can't tell the
difference between even cubic circle
the cubic circle is like a two on the
hardness scale so you have to switch it
out everywhere like i would want to be a
real diamond like i'm not saying like
give me kubrick's accordion because i
don't want it to scratch and i want it
to last a long time dude i want it like
just visually i can't i can't tell yeah
give me the fakest [ __ ] i don't care i
don't even care give me a lab grown if
that's if you want to the only reason i
wanted it to be a diamond is be like you
said for it to last a long time yeah
because visually i can't tell right and
most people can't tell especially like
even if you take there's youtube videos
where they take two different rings like
a diamond and moistening and people are
like i have no idea you know so anyway i
wanted to go with this option because it
was the better option for a budget it
was a better option i just wouldn't feel
comfortable wearing like a big ass
diamond and
we're not gonna spend forty thousand
five yeah fifty thousand on a diamond
and i like a bigger stone i have bigger
hands
so it looks so good that looks really
pretty so much i love it so anyway so
danny told me he was completely into
that idea he was like yes i want you to
love it i want you to
i want you to be infatuated with the
ring so i actually went to go
design the ring myself
and then uh after that he went to buy it
so i wasn't there throughout the whole
process of designing the ring but then
after that i don't i don't know when he
bought it i don't know when they gave it
to him
so i kind of knew the proposal was
coming i just didn't know when yeah and
that was kind of a little bit
nerve-wracking because i i have anxiety
a little bit so anytime we would go out
i'm like holy [ __ ]
it might happen you know every time you
bend down tie a shoe oh god
so that is the only thing you know like
um i i love the fact that i was in the
planning process and i love the fact
that i chose the ring
but it's just that whole knowing
oh that was the only thing where i was
like oh my god it was torture but when
it happened i wouldn't have changed it
to be any other way so
uh for those of you guys who want to
know who are into jewelry it's a 3.85
radiant cut moissanite and yellow gold
with pave in the band nice yeah so
there's pictures on my instagram if you
guys want to see him but the fact that i
picked it to the detail yeah he loved
that and i love that it just worked
really well for us because you want
you're wearing it forever like so you
want something that you look down and
you're like oh my god i'm in love and
that's what it feels like what was the
timeline how long was it from the day
that you chose the ring to proposal when
did you choose a ring so i chose the
ring in
march oh this year yeah it was this year
yeah so i chose the ring in march
yeah and then he proposed in august
so it took him around four months um
from when we got the ring to now you
know and it was just
wait was it march now it might have been
may so it was even faster oh wow it was
me because i remember when you vlog when
you went shopping it was like casey's
birthday
yeah so uh so it happened really fast
from buying the ring to
getting it uh but i'm just i'm on i'm
really happy with it yeah it was a
really wonderful experience and honestly
to get to be engaged feels amazing
especially to a man you love and who i
trust and rely on and who makes me feel
like
he has my back and he makes me feel
protected he makes me feel loved like i
wish and pray for all for this for all
of you guys listening to you do you feel
a difference don't you yes because some
people like oh my god i guess like from
what i've heard of people who haven't
gotten married or got engaged or
anything like that they're like what's
the point of getting married like it's
just a piece of paper it's no big deal
and that's fine like you could totally
believe that yeah and that's kind of
what i like before getting engaged and
before getting married like i kind of
had those ideas too it's kind of like ah
it's just it's legal whatever it's like
you're still gonna be the same like
you're still gonna love each other but
holy [ __ ] do you feel completely
different like it's a completely new
level that like mentally in your
relationship that you get to where you
feel like this complete sense of
security and like yeah bond and like
it's another level it feels amazing it
really does and i feel like because if
there was a point where like i was even
like well why would why would we get
married like what's the point blah blah
blah you know so this was before i had
like a really close i'm i'm growing my
relationship to god closer so before i
would be like well what's the point now
it's like we want to unify that in the
eyes of god and in the eyes of each
other right
but now that i'm living through it like
even my personality like being a bride
is fun
and then seeing danny and being like oh
my god like i get to share my life with
you like before i would be like what's
the point like why would you do all that
like he could he has his own hands he
could do his he could iron his own shirt
but now i love him so much i'm like i
want to do this yeah it's your family
now like it's like solidified your
family now yeah not just like my partner
that's the perfect way to put it yeah
it's like your family and you could have
a family without being married if that's
what you choose but it just feels so
official like in the eyes of god and in
the eyes of the government i'm willing
to
to be one with your taxes
in the eyes of your
cpa most importantly well that means we
have a wedding to go too soon that means
you want to look your best and wear a
cute outfit right however i don't like
picking out my own outfits because i'm
lazy and that's where stitch fix comes
along uh shopping for new clothes can be
time consuming tedious and expensive
fortunately stitch fix makes it easy to
find the clothes that you love stitch
fix offers clothing hand selected by
expert stylist for your unique size
style and budget stitch fix offers
clothing hand selected by expert
stylists for your unique size style and
budget it's a completely different and
fun way to find clothes that you will
love to wear every piece is chosen for
your fit and your life and it's the easy
solution to finding what makes you look
and feel your best you go on their site
you take a quiz you pick outfits that
they put on there and then they start
forming a wardrobe for you i like
anything that has a quiz because yeah
um easy quiz you can try on the pieces
at home before you buy it keep what you
love and return what you don't stitch
fix has free shipping easy returns and
exchanges and a prepaid return envelope
is included which makes it so easy just
toss whatever you want in that bag and
send it off there's no subscription
required try stitch fix once or set up
automatic deliveries you'll pay just a
20 styling fee for each box which gets
credited towards pieces that you keep
and there are no hidden fees ever and
it's not only for women it's also for
men and kids they ship all over the us
and also they're available in the uk
so get started today at stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix that's
stitchfix.com
for 25 off
when you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
mood for 25 off and speaking of feeling
good in your clothes you just want to
feel good in general right so shout out
to feels um feels as a cbd brand and cbd
isn't just about what you feel it's also
about what you don't feel so no stress
anxiety pain and feels is a better way
to feel better
so um cbd for me i have a lot of anxiety
first of all and i felt like it just
kind of cut the edge off without making
you feel any like
like you don't feel any side effects as
if you were to drink a glass of wine or
or like smoke something you know you're
just reducing the anxiety without
anything extra it's like you without
that and i also have a lot of back pain
and i notice that when i use cbd and
feels um that
the back pain just kind of disappears
i'm not saying it's gone completely but
i don't think about it anymore it's
normally like at the forefront of my
mind because like it's painful but
with cbd uh no it's gone they also have
creams that you can put on your back
anyway
um yeah so cbd naturally helps reduce
stress anxiety pain and sleeplessness if
you have trouble falling asleep there's
no hangover or addiction you just place
a few drops of fields under your tongue
and then you feel the difference within
minutes the thing to remember about cbd
is that finding your right dose is
really important and everyone's dose is
different so play around with that
joining the fields monthly memberships
makes your self-care very easy you save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel at any time so start feeling
better with feels become a member today
by going to
big mood and you'll get 50 off your
first order with free shipping that's f
e a l s dot com slash big mood to become
a member and get 50 off automatically
taking off your first order with free
shipping fields.com
big mood big mood
okay i have so many questions still yeah
um
one where did you put all the flowers
oh my gosh
so that was it for sure the biggest book
i had ever gotten in my life so it was
huge and normally so danny goes to the
same lady all the time like he has his
flower lady and
this bouquet was literally like a bunch
of them together because normally they
wrap them so you can't really see what
they look like at the bottom
but she literally put like tape to like
pull it together and then she wrapped it
together so it looked nice on the
outside i had to go to home goods and
get a vase that was literally like this
oh my god and then i got another vase on
the side so there was like i separated
them into two um but i've literally
broken like two vases at some point
because he gets me flowers all the time
thank god um where like they'll be so
big that they kind of like crack the
vase
yeah so i mean it's not a bad problem to
have yeah i love that problem i
personally love getting flowers and i
love that he thinks of me so yeah that's
where they i wish it would have lasted
forever honestly
i was carrying them from like my kitchen
to my room at
night a baby on the hip hot cooking this
will be good for your wedding because
maybe it's too late for those flowers
but um you're able to save your flowers
from your wedding day um by it's like
you put it in resin like preserving it
yeah yeah and i did it with our flowers
but i think i got them in there too late
like you have to do it right after the
wedding but i got them in there like a
day after and i think it was like just a
little bit too late but if you put it in
the special mix and you can google it um
it was such a helpful tip i found out
about it right before the wedding
because you have to order it online
because it's like a lot of resin yeah
they have it at craft stores but not
enough
anyway um it preserves the color too so
it preserves everything and then you can
frame them and you just have them in a
frame so i have ours framed but they
look like dried flowers as opposed to
like fresh consistency of wow dude i
wanted to save my bouquet so badly but
we were
we were in france there was no way i was
like yeah yeah i don't like my boyfriend
because in france
i know people used to save the the top
tier of their cake
someone
oh my god and the caterers took our food
well not the caterers the event staff
at the venue yeah so we had tons of food
i was so looking for because i barely
got to eat on the wedding day because
you're just like talking to everybody
you have to make sure to eat a little
bit because otherwise you'll pass out
but you know like you're probably i got
the i got we got trejos tacos and it was
so bomb but i was like i couldn't eat i
was just filled with emotions and i was
like looking forward to it like tomorrow
i'm going to [ __ ] feast
they stole all of the food didn't even
leave anything and there were tons of
leftovers because we had buffet style so
there was tons of leftovers and i kept
eyeballing it throughout the night i was
like make sure that we pack that in the
car and it was gone at the end of the
night and then my [ __ ] dumbass uncle
was drunk as [ __ ] took the top of the
cake and all the cupcakes he tried to
carry like all what he was like trying
to steal him and take him back to his
hotel room and he just took like all the
cupcakes and like because we had
cupcakes instead of cake and then we had
like a special top tier cake for us and
he just took all of it and dropped them
oh my god
and i don't have the topper either how
did you not have a complete meltdown i
was
quote unquote the chillest bride that
any photographer like all my
photographers had ever seen i didn't
know what to expect because i'd never
been to a wedding i was the bride at my
first wedding
so my mom and dad um got married on a
tuesday afternoon on their lunch break
they just went to their court or the
courthouse and signed a piece of paper
so all my life i just like didn't i
wasn't brought up like knowing about
weddings i went to a few when i was a
kid but i don't really remember the
details of it i just remember like
eating and there was cake and dancing
like so i was like okay so it's like a
birthday party but like a joint birthday
party yeah so like we need music and we
need like food and cake but other than
that like people were like what are your
colors i was like i don't [ __ ] know
i'm wearing white yeah so
i don't know and and then i didn't know
how expensive it was girl i thought it
was
legit i thought it was a thousand
dollars i thought it was gonna be like a
thousand dollars
not a thousand dollars
because i was like the most expensive
party i've ever thought was like five
hundred dollars how much was your your
dress alone
so well my dress i was trying to keep it
under a thousand i ended up going to
like 2 800. there's your whole party and
party so you're running
shout out to captain morgan because they
yeah they sponsored everything and they
owned don julio
it was literally
julio hit me it was
an open bar we had five signature
cocktails they made the bar menus they
got us an ice sculpture did you hit them
up or how did you do it i was already
working with them oh my god and so i was
like
dude you should because they're they're
really open to it they're so cool they
own a lot of brands they own smirnoff
they own a lot of brands that would
literally be in my vlog like this is
sponsored by non-hoodies yeah
i was like
like in your wedding video okay
we take a shot
we're going to renew our vows because i
wasn't i didn't know like that you could
plan out this whole whole palette and
color but i'm kind of jealous because
i'm like oh if i knew what i knew now i
would i would plan like so many cool
decorations i would have an actual
budget i would know what i was getting
into but yeah what surprised me the most
is the fact like before during my own
wedding i didn't know like when i would
go to weddings i didn't know that they
were paying for me to be there yeah oh
like the bride me getting invited right
right
i didn't know that each head was a price
tag
what the [ __ ] like until i started
planning my own i'm like well we're not
inviting these people
and your guests they don't know that
either unless they've planned their own
weddings because
dude steve's whole family straight up
rsvp didn't show up
so like his extended family not his his
immediate family but like yeah because
like if you don't plan your own wedding
you don't you just don't know parties
the first the first wedding i went to
consciously that i remember when i was a
kid
um i guess like their flower girl didn't
make it in time so they just yanked me
like here walk down and throw the
flowers right so that was the first
wedding i remember as a kid
and then the next weddings i went to
with my family i was like
so when do i throw the flowers
you're like i am the flower girl yeah
for everybody
they're like oh they pick like the
cutest kid there yeah
you get selected
i don't remember it at all okay yeah i
was a flower girl quite a few times but
yeah it's same i was so little that i
don't remember the details of a wedding
just like there was a bride and there
was food i didn't even know it was a
flower girl until years later
that like phone [ __ ] no no i i don't
have any memory of this wedding at all
like that's how young i was and then
years years later like i would see the
bride because she's a family member and
she'd be like oh i remember you a flower
girl at my wedding i was like huh like i
hadn't i never don't even remember no
wow i was really really little yeah like
maybe like three four like i was too
young yeah i was three but i for some
reason i remember it but
um yeah i asked my little cousin to be
the flower girl but she's 11 at the time
and it's just that age where like you're
too cool for things yeah she had older
siblings and the older siblings like
didn't want to be in it and so when she
went down the aisle you could watch this
on my video but she just took the pedals
just threw him at people
oh my god
she was just like so funny
she's like aggressive hippie yeah
there's just like flower petals she was
like
in people's faces
i wouldn't have it any other way like
every part of the wedding was like yeah
every detail like
dropping [ __ ] and losing my [ __ ] i was
like i don't know i don't care i just
want to be here yeah i'm just happy to
be here that's true wow
yeah i mean definitely now that i'm
planning i'm asking everybody like how
much did you spend how much did you say
yeah because it's incredible how much
you could spend on a wedding literally
you can i can buy you a cake for your
birthday and it'll be 120 dollars if i
put your wedding cake yeah 500
automatically exactly why we went to
europe because people think we spent so
i think you spent a lot of money yeah
okay well can i can i guesstimate no i
don't i don't want to talk about that
okay
but but i just i just want to make it be
known
if we had this exact same wedding in the
united states we would have paid like
triple like
double triple i'm probably exaggerating
but for sure way more than what we
picked i think the average in california
is 50 right
50 people no 50 thousand dollars like oh
no no yeah so because when we got
married it was the average the national
average was 26 000.
and uh that was like four or five years
ago and so now i think it's at like 40
000 maybe more they say that you should
like you almost have like trick the um
those those vendors no you can't you
can't so they they retroactively bill
you if they find out it was for a
wedding oh yeah i tried i was looking
into it
yeah because we tried to keep ours under
10 000 which i thought was an extreme
amount of money 10 because we were
trying to buy a house at the time yeah
so i was like that's like part of my
down payment like that's a crazy amount
of money and everyone i talked to was
like ten thousand dollars is ultra low
budget that's like you're going to have
a hard time keeping it wait were you
able to are you comfortable sharing i'm
comfortable sharing how much was it
i will say our budget was ten thousand
dollars my parents were like we will
give you ten thousand dollars on top of
that you can either use it for a house
or you can use it for your wedding
so i was like yeah i was super grateful
for that i was like that's a lot of
money to me um but the same day that i
was trying on my wedding dress that i
was like i gotta keep this under a
thousand dollars uh i got a call from my
manager and i booked a brand deal for 10
grand for just one
shout out in a video for vodka for a
different podcast um and
and so i was like all right and so then
i was like i think that's a sign that i
can get the dress i actually want and
yeah that's amazing because the one i
got felt like pajamas it is so pretty
but it feels it was made out of this
patented material that was like pajamas
i actually fell asleep in it
dude mine were pajamas too yeah yeah it
was wait what do you mean like the the
material it just feels so sleek like
really
mine was more like um it was like a
heavy pajama because the beads the beads
yeah yeah but like the actual material
was like this like stretchy like yeah
really really comfy it was really nice
mine was a thousand i could tell you
that you're just where
um so
uh what is it called beholden is the
name but oh anthology yeah so
anthropology has a bridal
section and it's called beholden but
it's like but it's shortened like
b-h-l-n
or something like that and that's where
i got my dress i'm like i don't [ __ ]
need a designer dress i don't need like
a unique dress like and that that was
the only website that i found that
actually gave the prices of the wedding
dress online oh and so i found my dress
and i'm like that's the one
so you didn't even go try them on no i
did i did oh you had two dresses too the
chinese oh the chinese ones yeah that
was like 150 so pretty well yeah 150. so
i'm not getting married anytime soon
however my my little sister just got
engaged a few days ago guys
she did yeah
it's really cute i got to help pick up
the ring yeah that's amazing
shout out to sam and your [ __ ] ass
fiance now um but now that means i'm
made of honor for the first time oh wow
no no no
you don't want to be that's a lot of
work it is
i can't plan things yeah that's why i
didn't have any bridal
party at all i'm like i'm making you
guys fly out all the way to france i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] already i'm not going to
do this don't make me fly out any time
let's go to france so i'm i'm like
should i just hire the person who did my
birthday party just have her plan
everything you know but now i'm like
[ __ ] i gotta write a speech no and it's
a wedding she'll charge you so much more
unless you know her personally
yeah um yeah probably but now i have to
write a speech and i was like i don't
know
should i just go typical speak
from your heart gina you know how to
talk
[ __ ] today i don't lose i don't lose a
sister but i gained a brother no you
don't be you be you still
wow i would boo you
i hardly know this girl but look at them
in love dude no cap though okay so i had
two maid of honors because um i have too
many votes really yeah so i have my
friend that like we had promised like a
decade before that was like if i get
married first you have a maid of honor
and we called each other mo like the
entire time cute but she's not the most
like responsible person so then i ended
up making my like really responsible
friend mate of honor she'd already been
made of honor at a lot of people's
weddings and she's like i felt like i
was closer to her at the time i was
getting married than that than the other
friend but i didn't want to take away
that because we had promised so long ago
and the first friend got so
[ __ ] drunk before her speech
and she ended up in the middle of her
speech she was squatting down in the
middle of the dance floor and she was
like
trying to read her phone from her phone
and she kept getting lost it went over
like 15
he minutes dyed her hair bright neon
purple and blue right before the wedding
and everyone all my other bridesmaids
were like aren't you [ __ ] mad are you
[ __ ] pissed and i was like i don't
should i be like i don't i don't know
anything but where why why am i mad tell
me why i imagined and then they're like
she's gonna ruin all your pictures like
she's gonna take over like she's gonna
steal a spotlight and i was like [ __ ] i
didn't think about that you know like
and the only reason i cared was because
photography
was something i splurged on i spent like
four grand on photography and um i was
like yeah that that's gonna be did you
end up caring afterwards then at that
point no well i just moved her to the
end so that she could get cropped out if
we need you to and we told her to like
so i didn't tell her but the other
bridesmaids like were like hey we're
going to move your order yeah in the
line and i learned so much from my own
wedding because i didn't know there were
certain like etiquettes like that like
don't dye your hair if you're in the
bridal party so for my best friend's
wedding my best friend since high school
um this was like the first wedding i was
a part of i was a bridesmaid and this is
when i had my bright pink and purple
hair and i i didn't like one day like i
think like a week or two before the
wedding was like oh [ __ ] this is gonna
look weird so i hit her out i texted her
i was like hey do you want me to have
brown hair so i don't stick out she goes
oh my god i didn't know how to tell you
i didn't know how to ask you i was like
yeah i got you so like yeah
because you have the same hair for our
wedding you asked me like oh do you want
me to wear my wigs
okay wait let's go back to that point
about her getting drunk first of all i
just picked my bridesmaids yesterday i
asked them i wanted to ask you about
that and so okay here's where we go type
a again so i made a list of require not
requirements but expectations and
expenses before i even asked them and i
know for those who don't know me you
guys are gonna be like what a [ __ ] no i
actually like that i did but to me it's
considerate yeah to me it's just like if
you know everything that's expected of
you act apart yeah we're all grown-ups
we're all grown women you know so um i
made the list like it was like a nice
cover letter it was wrapped in a pink
ribbon you know and then i had all the
expectations and all the expenses that
way they wouldn't know because yeah if
somebody that's nice yeah i would be
like that's considerate just [ __ ] yeah
i don't care i know you were like you
look a mess girl you know what i mean so
everyone's different but yeah that's
something i'm like yeah
my so my siblings and i have a pact that
whenever we get married someone has to
wrangle my mother oh my birthday angle
as in like keep her in check and control
because this [ __ ] goes crazy when she
drinks so the last time my aunt got
married the young is on my mom's sister
she was drunk on the mic we were all
eating dinner there was nobody even like
emcee wasn't even talking all of a
sudden we hear hey
and then like she just
my aunt's name i'll just say my own name
was like michelle or something like
michelle you know
for the longest time we thought you were
a lesbian oh my god because he didn't
bring a guy home that's how my grandma
was there yeah and then my sister and my
brother
are like what the [ __ ] we turn around
you just tackle her yeah right and then
she's like um but
i'm so glad you have a husband finally
someone you actually brought home and
um make sure you make kids okay because
we just don't we don't want just dogs
and it's just just like someone just had
to like yank her and take her away from
the mic so my siblings and i are like
we have to run interference for any of
our weddings or i'm locking her in a
[ __ ] hotel room oh yeah yeah so
that's going to be really interesting
yeah do you guys have family members
like that for your wedding so speaking
of getting your family under control
under control are you speaking of that
are you looking for no
yeah uh you should if you are on birth
control
you should hit up the pill club yes
unless you want to look like this yeah
because you know i'm expecting and i no
longer need birth control because you if
you're not trying to look like me though
then you do need your birth control this
should have been my ad if you don't want
crotch goblins
take these candy things yeah exactly and
if you are on birth control remembering
to take your pill is already enough work
so it is pretty hard yeah like forget
going to the doctor in person to get
your prescription and picking up from
the pharmacy because the pill club wants
to help take the work out of taking care
of yourself
so the pill club is a birth control
subscription prescribed by a medical
professional and delivered straight to
your door for free the pill club carries
over 120 fda approved brands and most
brands of birth control are free with
insurance or medicaid
otherwise prices start as low as seven
dollars per month without insurance the
pill club delivers birth control to your
door for free and discreet packaging and
their licensed medical team is just a
text away to give you the best
reproductive health care so skip the
office visit and waiting in line at the
pharmacy and join the club can i just
say how awesome this is because um i one
time had to be late to my grandma's
funeral because uh yeah cause my
freaking ob gyn didn't tell me that i
needed to call them before my pills
could get refilled and so i went to go
pick up my pills they weren't there it
was the weekend it was a sunday so i had
to go to planned parenthood and it was
like a two-hour wait and i ended up
being late for my grandma's funeral
because i couldn't skip a pill otherwise
it messes you all up and yeah it was
just a nightmare so this would have been
this one yeah and the last time some
planned parenthood fans came up to me
like can i get a picture i'm like bro
we're gonna plan another place not not
not please please at least take a
picture with me away from the sign see
you don't have to watch it anymore gina
yeah yeah with the pill club thank you
you'll have to worry about all that
embarrassment or being late to your
grandma's funeral uh right now i'll be
late to our funeral yeah don't ask me
for pictures of planned parenthood
[ __ ]
go on yeah right now when you go to
thepillclub.com
big mood the pill club is offering a 10
donation to bedsider.org for every big
mood listener who becomes a patient your
donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org that's the
pillclub.com big mood to get your first
birth control care package and donate to
help more women in need of affordable
birth control remember the pill club.com
big mood you must use the link to make a
donation and if you're not pregnant
enjoy being not pregnant by having some
wine we got great sellers sponsoring the
show today shout out to them um fall is
coming and if you're like me that means
cozy sweaters pumpkin spice lattes and
switching over to red wine i actually
almost
uh
only drink red wine i will have a
vignette in the summertime though that's
healthier they say yeah it helps your
heart that's why i take it because i
want to be healthy yeah there you go
um if you're a seasonal wine drinker or
just looking for a change of pace this
fall you need to try bright sellers okay
so you're going to go on this
gina you like quizzes you go online you
take a quiz on what kind of foods you
like it'll be like what kind of
chocolate do you like do you like
reese's pieces do you like dark
chocolate and you pick one and then
you're like uh it'll ask you you know
what kind of uh smells do you like what
kind of candles do you like and you just
pick a bunch of stuff that you like and
it'll curate a wine box for you where
you have like a selection of five
different wines
six six different ones thank you even
better six different wines that you can
try and you can always switch up the
number of reds whites and roses if
you're a seasonal wine drinker and you
can skip an order whenever you want to
the best part is that is that if you
don't like a bottle of wine bright
cellars offers a delight guarantee and
will send you a replacement bottle on
your next order so you can be like meh
take it back garcon but also you can
have it still and then they'll send you
a replacement bottle so that's pretty
cool help support us by supporting
bright sellers for a limited time big
mood listeners get 50 off their first
six bottle box by going to
brightsellers.com mood it's basically
six bottles of wine for the price of
three
to get fifty percent off your first box
head to brightsellers.com that's b r i g
h t
c e l l a r s dot com
backslash mood bright cellar is helping
you discover a wine you love and i will
say all the ones that they sent me i did
love i don't know how they nailed it
just by me saying what kind of
chocolates and candles i like yeah but i
love pinot noir and they sent so many
great pinot noirs to my house oh yeah oh
my god i
actually got bright cellars way before i
got pregnant and i agree like they just
nail it perfect so hmm so we were
talking about your mom yeah your mom
yeah yeah so that's that's that's gonna
be a thing at every wedding and the
whole family knows it too
the thing is like
the thing about weddings is asian
weddings are [ __ ]
wild like i don't need every 16th cousin
there but like asian parents i was like
but we got to invite them so there's
like 100 200 people big but wow i've
like unlike my
birthday um i actually would want to do
a very low key and do like a courthouse
wedding and that's it
you were like really you i know no [ __ ]
you no i want to go to your wedding so
[ __ ] you for that no seriously gina you
want me to be at the courthouse and
they'll be like if anyone speak now or
forever hold you i'm gonna be picketing
like i need a party that's not fair why
would you do that to us did we not know
you that well when my birthday happened
oh
way though like so my auntie speaking of
asians um bunch of filipinos in my
family uh my aunt sheila is crazy and
she was the first one drunk she's
married to my drunk uncle that um
and she ends up dancing with tim
deleguetto and and like there's a an
instagram story something like an
instagram story i think tim put it on
his stories i can't remember he was like
dancing with the drunk aunties at a
wedding and it went viral
she got so excited because she like felt
famous she didn't even attack her or
anything but she was just like i'm viral
i'm famous
yeah so funny tim's a
video went viral recently too on tick
tock it was
um at their wedding he and chia were
dancing and then it was just someone was
recording he was like feed me yeah you
can't hear the sound oh yeah he goes
and she gives them food it was the
cutest thing ever
did you go to their wedding i was yeah
it was a cute wedding yeah the dj was
great and the food was wonderful too
yeah it was an amazing venue yeah it was
beautiful did you guys pick out your
first song or your first time no girl
nothing yeah dude there's so much that
goes into it there's so many little
details that you don't even think of
like having an extra bouquet of throw
like that you're not holding so that you
don't waste the wellness yeah
all this [ __ ] i not one thing or i i
guess just two things i
like we both wanted to incorporate him
to the wedding which was the tea
ceremony and the mexican money dance oh
yeah oh i just thought that too but i
didn't do it because i was too
embarrassed i was like oh no i provided
the money because i was too embarrassed
to ask people yeah
i got 100
bills and like a stack of so that's nice
and i'm like here you go guys we're
doing this next time i was so scared
during that dance because i was like
stand still stop moving stop dancing
please i don't want to poke you please i
will see you i was so mad too because my
wedding planner she ended up switching
out the safety pins for the tiniest
[ __ ] little shits that you can't even
use because i bought i bought the big
ones and i was like where the [ __ ] are
my safety pins i was pissed dude that
happened so many times with like we had
a wedding coordinator not a wedding
planner
and i just had like certain things i'd
picked out from etsy to like
like have happen and those little things
like you you'll notice little things
that you plan
won't happen like there's something
that's gonna go wrong and i told myself
this beforehand you just like no one
else will notice though so you can't
freak out about it but it's just like
little things that i was like oh man
like i just i bought those and i planned
it i actually did a video series on my
channel though for anyone that doesn't
know
how to plan weddings because it was like
my first it was me doing it while i was
learning what i was supposed to be doing
and learning how much everything costs
and like trying to save money on a
budget we did our invitation invitations
they'll charge you an arm and a leg
forward
and they were nice my save the dates i
got them on booster yeah there's the
prince great my invitations i'm getting
them in mexico oh okay nice you guys
already know i go to everything yeah for
everything over there so yeah for sure
and so i'm getting the invitations over
there
uh we're gonna go dress shopping over
there to see what the dress what dresses
we might find uh what else are we
getting from you already have a date huh
yes can you say it or do you wanna i
do you have a timeline on like um have
you guys talked about like i mean
because you're talking about being type
a you have a timeline for like kids or
you have you guys talk to you yes
so
so i don't i would love for us to have
kids right after we get married
um but i think number one we just have
to be thoughtful that you know like
like rihanna says we plan and god laughs
so we just have to be thoughtful of that
you know because i want to be pregnant
all i want i've never been pregnant
before so i just would like i don't know
how my fertility is i don't know any of
those things i just want to think i'm
healthy and everything's going to go
great you know but i don't want to think
oh you guys when we're married expect
the pregnancy announcement because you
know how this job could be like i don't
want that pressure to also be on me and
then i'm like imagine i don't get
pregnant within the first six months and
then you're starting to question
yourself so i would love to have a child
as soon as we're married but i would
also like the space to allow us to get
pregnant within our own time yeah you
know without the pressure of people
being like because of course the viewers
are happy for you and they want to see
those things happen for you
but i think like you've shared in your
video a lot goes on behind the scenes
that it's really hard to share and i'm
not calling that on to myself but
uh i would love for that to happen
sooner than later after we're married
but it's just it's whenever god wants it
to happen because there's so many
expenses involved too because you know
the case the wedding is expensive but
then the honeymoon expenses and then
it's like do we get a house right away
do we have kids like all of these are
like
budget considerations for sure i would i
wouldn't mind and this is just my
personality i wouldn't mind renting
while i'm pregnant or like rent or
having a kid while i'm renting uh the
only reason being is i'm 30 and you know
there's people who have kids way later
in life but i want to be i'm not going
to be a young mom but i want to be a
younger mom yeah you know i don't really
want to be in my late 30s and be a
first-time mom i would like to be
a first-time mom in my early 30s and
then the second kid in my mid-30s and
that's if everything goes according to
plan yeah you know so i would like to
give myself that timeline and that space
to not really be rushed in my mid to
late 30s to be like i have to get
pregnant now yeah yeah um so yeah like
by setting other things as priorities
yeah like the house is cool but i don't
mind getting a house later on in life um
so that's kind of how we're seeing and
going about it the
the marriage was important for me to
happen first for sure
for both of us to happen first um
well maybe if it was up to danny he
would have gotten me pregnant when he
met me but
i wanted to get married first i wanted
to have that commitment and then the
babies are probably what's next for us
and then hopefully if the house happens
effortlessly within that yeah then
that's amazing but if not then it's okay
yeah that's great i love that so you're
like you know here's a plan but i'm
flexible for sure that's the way you got
to do it i think so especially because
what is certain in this life right
nothing you know
is that that's the one taxes
death and taxes are the only two things
we have for certain but uh yeah for sure
i didn't always know that being a mom
was like a thing for me like after
before i would think like i don't really
know it's a lot of responsibility blah
blah blah but as i've gotten older and
i've kind of settled in my life like i
found a partner that i love my career is
going well i'm like you know what i'm
ready for that and i would love to share
my life with a human that comes from my
fiance and i yeah my husband at the time
you know i think he's a great man and he
would make a great father and i think i
would do okay you know so yeah so i
think we we're a good team i feel like i
kind of went the opposite where like i
always wanted to be a mom yeah and then
the later the more i i liked my life i
was like oh no i don't know i don't know
like
like we steve and i have been on the
fence for years now like we were trying
a couple years ago and the pandemic
happened and i'm like oh i don't want to
get pregnant during the pandemic because
they weren't letting husbands come to
the appointments and all this stuff and
i just i'm a baby like i don't i need to
be with him if we're doing all that
stuff so we put it on pause and now
we're like older and i'm like i'm
turning 35 this year and i'm like oh i
mean i kind of gotta make a choice but
yeah i really like
our life right now so it's kind of like
okay
we're not on birth control
we
don't pull out so
if something happens then it happens but
i don't know at this point it's kind of
like up to god yeah yeah yeah and there
was i think i was talking to
i don't know
i don't i forgot who i was talking to
but she was also telling me how there
came a point where she got past a
certain age where she was like well it's
done for me like i'm not having kids and
i remember asking her like how did you
feel about that like was that something
that you kind of struggle with and she
was like no i was fine with it you know
um and everybody's life is different
everybody's choices are different and
things change in your mind for sure they
do because look at no i never i was
never the type to be like i need to be
pregnant and have a child yeah or even
married you said and yeah and now i'm
like i need to be pregnant and have a
child yeah i i don't know what it is and
hopefully like every mother you talk to
they're always like it's hard
it's hard but what i've learned from
life is that a lot of the things that
are worth it are hard yeah you know the
harder something is the more you value
it right and the more you you feel
accomplished right like a marathon
owning a multi-million dollar business
those are all hard things that people do
and those are things that people hold a
lot of pride in so i think personally to
be a mother would be a privilege yeah
absolutely and i am happy i will say
like even though i'm having kids a lot
later than i thought i would i remember
like early in life i was like i'm not
having kids at 24. and then i was like
okay 26. yeah okay 30.
and um i am happy though because i've
been through so much therapy since 30
that i'm like oh i was not ready to
take care of another life before at that
point in my life um whereas now if i
were to have a child i feel
pretty prepared like mental health-wise
and like
understanding psychological aspects that
could affect them
later and and so i am really thankful
that
i'm ha i would have kids for sure now if
that was yeah exactly how i feel too
like and especially in terms of like our
our relationship because like
we've been married for almost five years
now and we wanted like the plan was to
like
be married for a whole year and travel
and like enjoy each other and that's
also something that casey wanted because
a lot of people think that's just what i
wanted but casey really wanted that too
and so that's what we did and then after
that one year of traveling and
everything i'm like our marriage was
like whoa
we're not in the place at all to add
more family members yeah we need to work
on our [ __ ] and we really made a
conscious effort to to like pause that
because we felt like it was more
important to get to a better mental
space a better a better
like relationship like better bonding
better understanding before we brought
in another life yeah it's because like
mandatory well another thing and then
also like by me already experiencing
being a teen mom and like having a
failed relationship and having my son
have to live in two homes like
i don't want to [ __ ] do that i don't
want to bring more kids into this world
and have them go through that either
because i went through that too and i'm
like the cycle ends here like yeah we're
not gonna have more kids until we're
good and ready and like we're [ __ ]
locked in and like we're we're solid
and yeah not until like we finally got
to that place and then like you know
you're talking a lot about god like i
really
i really believe like god the universe
the source or whatever is
was like okay now's your time yeah you
know because like even like what
happened with our previous pregnancy and
like having that loss like
that was a lesson like i'm like there
was a lot going on at that time even
even like with um me and like my own
mental space and all that stuff i'm like
it was even though
we got pregnant like two months later in
that first pregnancy in that time like
obviously that just wasn't meant to be
and it wasn't the right time so
yeah like well talk about your nails
they're rainbows yeah because you got a
rainbow baby exactly
yes before our birth
what not birth the pregnancy
announcement
um i got the these nails done because i
wanted to like
kind of like celebrate and also like oh
wait that experience you don't know what
rainbow baby is you want to explain to
them yeah so they say like after you
have a pregnancy loss or a child loss
that your next pregnancy your next baby
is a rainbow baby because it's like the
rainbow comes after the storm
and so
that's what exactly like this baby is
and
you know like we didn't want to
brush that experience under the rug we
didn't want to pretend like oh that that
didn't happen like let's move on like
now we're pregnant like it happened two
months later whatever like
i i just wanted to honor that experience
and
but not also be like
super like in your face like
rainbow like i don't know like a whole
reason
so i just wanted to have like a little
touch like a little token of like that
experience and then honoring that
experience when we announced this baby
um and and yeah like the fact that this
baby is a rainbow baby so like when i
pulled up the ultrasound photos i was
like oh yeah there's my nails like this
is like
it's perfect like a little
yeah like a reminder yeah reminder of
commemorating like right exactly what
you guys are went through because that
wasn't the journey it was an important
traumatic event that happened to us it
shaped us and it shapes it's gonna shape
like how we view this baby too because
it's just like a miracle baby like that
much more special precious oh i'm so
excited i already want to like squeeze
its stupid little cheeks i just want to
see its face i want to see like
the combination of you two in a child
like that's my favorite part of seeing a
baby is like who do they look like yeah
i'm so ready to bully this baby so hard
i'm a cyber bully since like from day
one
yeah i already have
yeah
yeah
the chocolate are you ready for the
wedding so i'm not against adopting but
i also like selfishly really want to see
the combination of being small like i
want to see the
baby's face
crazy too like we can we can already
know what what we're having like the sex
of the
baby are you having a gender reveal
party so that's the thing like we're
deciding to not know the the
sex the gender until facebook party i
know
you're gonna have a baby shower though
right we're gonna plan it yeah i'm like
i don't know that's that's out of my
hands
hey i didn't have a wedding registry i
told like we told all of our wedding
guests like don't buy us anything your
your presence is your present like yeah
i had to buy a plane ticket jesus no
exactly
exactly i'm like i recognize we're
[ __ ] [ __ ] for making you
go all the way but
it filters out the the real friends yeah
yeah it was awesome it was fun i would
have done it so then yeah so then for
this baby i'm like hey
i'm out of one income source like you
might as well [ __ ]
well actually we need diapers
wait you do want to have like baby
showers honestly gender reveals all the
parties because then you can i don't
want to plan it it feels it feels weird
no you don't plan your baby shower no
right it's your friend's plan yeah yeah
yeah just have as many parts as possible
because the diapers yeah have diaper
content yeah like okay you guys are
going to win like a raw's base or like
one of these bottle holders if you bring
diapers you know because you're going to
need a lot of diapers girl
coupon one babysitting day from theaters
can you give me actual money
no but yeah knowing that the gender is
already like formed it's it's not like
it's in my house yeah it's in my phone i
could pull it up whenever i wanted to
you can't do that can i i know it's been
touring oh yeah
yourself like that i know can we see no
can we see so we could like get there
isaac really wants to know too even our
doctor she was like okay you don't want
to know the sex i am not going to know
the sex so i don't slip up so not even
our doctor knows the only person in the
planet that knows is the girl who called
me to tell me the test results and she
was like oh do you want to know the sex
and i'm like no she was like okay and
i'm like wait can when you send me the
results can you like cut that out and
she goes no i'm sorry the results are
just all there like you can see because
they're testing for genetic things like
down syndrome and all that stuff i'm
gonna have a phone so she was like she
was like your test results will be there
she's like just don't scroll far like oh
my past a certain point so then one time
i was torturing myself and i pulled out
my phone
and then i was looking at the test
results i'm like okay negative negative
okay cool and then i covered my phone
with my hand and then i could see it
like six seconds
like
if i just go like this i could see it
dude no that would drive me oh my gosh i
couldn't handle it so we've like i've
had these results for like four weeks
like a month
and it's been torture and i'm like oh my
god we still have another like six
months to go just delete the app man oh
my god so you're trying to find out when
it pops out yeah so we want casey to
announce the sex and be like it's a boy
it's a girl oh like tell you
or the rules yeah oh the room i mean
yeah the room so just make it special
like yeah make it old school that's cute
can i see
anyway
no
if we don't get to know no one gets to
know because like i said isaac really
wants to know too and then he's like mom
can i just see it i'm like no you're
gonna slip up and like nope no one gets
it whenever that girl is i called about
the results and sent it if you're
watching this i'll send you 50 bucks
right now just just text me just let me
know message me on instagram yeah yeah
um so that's a lot of really exciting
things going on we got a wedding coming
soon we got a baby coming soon we got
her coming my husband coming soon yeah
her husband's coming soon and if there's
a baby you know yeah
uh but thank you guys for watching this
week's episode our updates and
everything going on in life stacy thanks
for being here tune in for more episodes
with stacy she's going to be with us for
quite a few more and also find her on
instagram yeah check out her jewelry
we'll put all the links in the
description she's got a youtube channel
check out her mom's youtube channel just
go on
share so much love over there okay and
make sure you guys give us a thumbs up
or five stars on everything and i'll
yelp i don't know um
check out our sponsors because that
helps us out a lot too to let them know
that we're doing our job right yeah help
me feed this baby and check out
whatever it is baby's gonna get a
cardboard sign when he comes he or she
comes out
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
next week bye